let's look let's take a look at some
statistical studies and see if we can
figure out what type they are so this
first one Roy's toys received a shipment
of 100,000 rubber duckies from the
factory the factory couldn't promise
that all rubber duckies are in perfect
form but they promised that the
percentage of defective toys won't
exceed 5% let me underline that they
promised that the percentage of
defective toys won't exceed 5% Roy
wanted to get an estimation of the
percentage of defective toys and since
he couldn't go over the entire 100,000
duckies he took a random sample of 10
duckies he found that 10% of them were
defective so what's going on here Roy
gets a shipment there's a hundred
thousand Ducks in the shipment he wants
to figure out what percentage of them
are defective he can't he can't look at
all 100,000 Ducks it's not practical so
he samples ten of them one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten and
he finds that one out of those ten are
defective ten percent of the ten so
first of all this is clearly a sample
study this is a sample study how do we
know that well he is taking a sample
from a broader population in order to
estimate a parameter the parameter is
the percentage of those hundred thousand
duckies that are actually defective now
the next question is is what kind of a
conclusion can you make you know Roy
since he got the shipment he and he took
a sample and he found that ten percent
of the sample was defective he might you
know be all up in arms and say oh this
this toy shipment from the factory you
know they violated this this promise
that the percentage of defective toys
won't exceed five percent because I
sampled ten toys and ten percent of
those ten toys were defective
well that isn't a reasonable conclusion
because this is a small sample this is a
small sample think about it he could
have sampled five duckies and if he just
happened to get one of the defective
ones he was said oh maybe twenty percent
are defective
what he's really got to do is sample
take a larger sample and once again
whenever you're sampling there's always
a probability
that your estimate is going to be not
close or definitely not the same as the
parameter for the population but the
larger your sample the higher
probability that your estimate is close
to the actual parameter for the
population and 10 on this is just too
low in future videos we'll talk about
how you can estimate the probability or
how you can figure out whether your
whether your sample seems sufficient but
for this one for what Roy did I don't
think 10 Ducky's is enough if he sampled
maybe a hundred duckies or more than
that and he found that 10% of them were
defective well that seems less likely to
happen just purely due to chance let's
do a few more of these and actually I'll
do those in the next videos